in a stunning reversal of Fortune
Elizabeth Holmes wants a Silicon Valley
Superstar was sentenced to more than 11
years in prison on Friday she was
convicted on fraud and conspiracy
charges earlier this year Holmes carried
out a massive scheme to deceive the
investors who put up nearly a billion
dollars in her biotech company theranos
Anna Werner was in the courtroom
Elizabeth Holmes holding hands with
family entered federal court in San Jose
California expressionless but just a few
hours later before her sentencing stood
in front of the judge weeping and told
him I stand before you taking
responsibility for theranos I loved
theranos it was my life's work she said
I am devastated by my failings every day
I have felt deep pain for what people
went through because I failed them judge
Edward Davila then sentenced her to 135
months over 11 years in federal prison
testing more accessible it was a
stunning fall for 38 year old homes who
had once seemed the Golden Girl of
Silicon Valley a Stanford University
Dropout who rocketed onto magazine
covers by launching her own blood
testing company in 2003 when she was
just 19 years old she then wowed
unsuspecting investors who poured
millions of dollars into what was
supposed to be a Cutting Edge company
earlier this year a jury convicted
Holmes on four counts of conspiracy and
fraud for misleading those investors
while acquitting her on another four
counts of defrauding patients the panel
was unable to reach a decision on the
remaining three charges
Holmes's attorneys had argued for a
sentence of 18 months of confinement at
home where homes now pregnant with her
second child could care for her toddler
and her new baby but after the judge
handed down the sentence prosecutors
said in a press release that it reflects
the audacity of her massive fraud and
the Staggering damage she caused the
judge ordered Holmes to turn herself in
in April next year for CBS Saturday
morning Anna Werner San Jose California